attitude is one of the most strongest
forms of power and attracting good
things you know if you truly feel
grateful for the things in your life
I always felt grateful for even the
small things I always used to celebrate
the small things now I might be
celebrating the bigger things but I
always celebrate every little good thing
that would happen to me in my life even
before I had any kind of money or either
I would celebrate and I would feel
grateful for it
and it just gave me more and this is
exactly the same thing that's happening
right now I still remain grateful and
more Coombes
of course I'm familiar with Muhammad Ali
you don't just have him here he is
global he is the man Muhammad Ali was a
guy that don't--what had not been done
before changed not only the face of his
game but the face of the world you know
he was a he was outspoken he fought for
what he believed in and that he was
charismatic he he he was a legend a hero
and I looked up to him one of my first
heroes was Muhammad Ali uh when I was 11
years old there was a group of people
and they tried to attack me and a fight
broke out and it was just me and one guy
before before everyone else jumped in on
me but we were fighting each other and I
slipped a punch and ice and I shuffled
my shoulders and said Muhammad Ali and
true a shot and he rolled under the shop
I fell into a knee and I ended up on top
of him
so I'm at the call him myself Muhammad
Ali and I'm punching him in the head and
then somebody came in and tried to kick
me and then a whole group and I came in
and we it was just a big fight but it
was me against six of them and I ended
up getting my ass whupped
I don't know Ali shuffle I'm only 11
years old I don't the Ali shuffle threw
a left hook he rolled him to the left
hook with it with it was good of him to
roll he started coming and rolled on it
but he rolled right into a knee yeah I
was I was I was prepared I was I was
studying tape so I know so definitely
Muhammad Ali was a hero of mine you just
watched two amazing clips from Conor
McGregor take the next three minutes to
sit quietly I think about how to apply
them to your business and your life
believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]